news broke on December 12th that Andre
Brower star of Brooklyn 99 passed away
the day before at the age of 61
reportedly from a short illness in the
wake of this tragic news the official
Brooklyn 99 Instagram account posted
always our captain we love you Andre
Terry Cruz who played Terren Terry
Jeffers on the show took to Instagram to
share his grief over the loss of his
coaster posting a head shot of Andre
Brower and a heartfelt message that read
in part can't believe you're gone so
soon I'm honored to have known you
laughed with you worked with you and
shared eight glorious years watching
your Irreplaceable Talent this hurts you
left us too soon thank you for your
wisdom your advice your kindness and
your friendship deepest condolences to
your wife and family in this difficult
time